okay we have e4 and
c5 by david pakman that means he has
been doing some studying because
oh yeah he's been playing evan and now
we're getting d6 and night or
okay all right this is gonna be
interesting
i think david has been preparing his
openings
from hawfi's games and so
bishop c4 which is what i would say most
players who are not so experienced to
play this movie because they usually
play it if black had played let me just
change the position very quickly
e5 they often go knight f3 and d6 bishop
c4 but the difference between this
and the game is that there's a pawn on
c5 and not a pawn on e5 so this pawn can
come to e6
and then to d5 later as we saw with
carson and scissors so
nemo early on there's a bishop on c4
which likely makes you happy because
italian player who is this opening
favorite
i'm going to say this opening favor is
xqc i feel like xqc does better in open
positions positions where he can push
pawns forward kind of like the last game
um except this in this kind of game he
can actually push the pawns forward on
the king's side because that's the style
of this opening
however um i don't know if he actually
knows how to play this structure it this
is
oh anyways d4 that's pretty good yes it
in andrea like this what so
nemo liking it from xqc side of things
is an open position which he seems to be
more comfortable with what about you do
you think that david pakman is the one
who chose the opening so
he feels good about it or does this
favor xqc in your opinion
i don't mind david's side because i play
the hype accelerated dragon which is
almost like
you get in this exact position um you
trade the c5 pawn for d4 fianchetto
i think it's comfortable to play for
black
so we don't know what you mean so you so
you frappuccino right
oh yes yes frappuccino i forgot how to
speak speak
the intellectual language here you speak
the language of pogchamps
yes thank you thank you university
of course and so both sides of castles
we have some good development for white
in the center of the board but nemo how
should
x2c continue here will he play move like
bishop g5 because that does feel like
the move that the
bishop
yeah uh the amount of times that we've
seen the sport today
oh and and pack david pac-man is like i
got that
[Music]
it's not over he may be going down a
piece but it's not over especially
because his pawn on d6 will be weak
so let's say white plays bishop g3 the
knight is captured the queen takes
you likely will be able to get a second
pawn on d6 and
the extra material doesn't make its
presence felt just yet
so that is also if he makes the correct
decision on which minor piece he should
give
yeah maybe he'll think to give the
bishop instead move his knight here
it's also a critical decision
i mean a move that xqc could potentially
play as knight b5
which will get you back the d6 bomb but
give up the
bishop so the other option is to save
the pair of bishops and
you know attack the d-pawn leader it's
it's uh there's not some choices here
for xqc
all the pepes in the chat are crying
right now
oh no well choice is
a bad thing at this point because you
know you're losing a piece
so spending time in addition to that
that doesn't seem like it's going to
help your chances so
yeah if he can make the next few moves
quickly i do think that david will slow
down a little
as he's up material and he doesn't want
a repeat of last week
so he will then start using some of his
clock and
trying to make sure that he wins the
game on the board so
xpc needs to just make a move at this
point yeah one thing
that players on this level i think
should cry more often is even when
they're losing try to put their
opponents in time pressure and speed up
um because many of them crumble under
time pressure
hey look i do that in my bloods games
too you know
it's a very good strategy you just press
your opponent have that confidence bluff
you know a lot of a lot of things that
could work
yeah and he's still burning clock now
he's down under
seven minutes in david pakman at 9 49
barely's used any time at this point and
it's unfortunate because as soon as xqc
made the move
he did that face bomb i know he's
defeated inside but maybe not
maybe not yeah and this is another thing
right you have to always remember to
never give up
because not giving up is also a really
really important part about playing
um chess especially in a situation where
anything could literally happen
you just you just just play your
opponent will probably blunder at some
point but you have to have the time you
have to have the right mentality to be
able to catch that blender
at that point which unfortunately won't
happen if you're spending a lot of time
right now but this is also where not
streaming is hurtful because when you're
streaming and you have a lot of people
supporting you even though you're not
reading the chat
you feel energized knowing that in
xqc's case 35 45 000
people are watching you you want to do
it for them now he's not streaming and
he's trying to do it for himself and
maybe he doesn't feel as motivated in
that regard right
that's a very interesting point i
definitely
feel energized when i have people in the
chat supporting me so
yeah i mean i think it's definitely
relate when i'm losing they're like
sad you're losing again loser point of
view only so they're not
always supposed that's true that's true
excuse me has very loyal fans so
like for force and they were still
cheering him on when she wasn't doing so
well
yeah and i know of course it's it's okay
to lose too it's okay to lose that
happens it always happens but it's just
like you know
at the end of the day they'll be here
for xqc the fans are here
and they're certainly in the chat right
now i see them
uh showing off their love and support of
xqc and i like what he did
actually putting his knight to b5
because if white were to
receive a free move and that's sometimes
how you should think about the position
and david
backman puts his queen on b6 but let's
say black and white h6
random move after the queen trade there
was knight to c7
trapping this rook on a8 so that's why
david pakman said you know i don't want
to give
knight access to the c7 square so it
puts his queen on b6
and in comes xqc's knight to d6 and i do
think that david pakman will be
somewhat concerned about the attack on
f7
yeah this is a very very good strat from
xcc he's playing aggressive chess which
we like to see despite being down a
piece he's not giving up i think
um you know just causing problems for
your opponent is always a good idea
yeah i like i like his idea a lot
putting pressure on f7
david is pretty good at spotting the
tactics now as robert said with queen b6
so he probably won't move his rook
anytime soon
and i think something that might be
tempting to some people is queen takes
b2 but
you're taking your queen away from the
defense
he did it wow i was going to say i
didn't think that david was going to do
that
oh this could change the entire game
xqc yeah he can bring this knight into
b5
which threatens c7 threatens to replace
the knight on d6 as you go after f7
and rook b1 will trap the queen down
here
he fell for the poison pawn yeah that's
not a pawn
that i thought he was going to take so
clearly i can't predict
all of their moves so i was a a one-game
commentator he's shaking his head he
knows he messed up the thing is
yeah i don't know if it's it's not that
bad but
um you know it's it's definitely gonna
complicate things for david
it's a lot more calculation than he
probably expected he's already up a
piece he probably is not thinking about
all these kind of things um he's just
like this game must be pretty easy for
me
so xc definitely has a good chance at
like you know making this game
complicated by playing
knight to b5 not an easy move to play i
must admit he takes an f7 which is
going straight for the king
and so there are some discovered checks
but
you probably just take it if you'd like
on f7
not to mention that this knight on c3
can be captured because once you take on
c3
the queen hits the bishop on c4 yeah
that's
i think that's the winning move for
black here because the eval bar
dropped that's a hard move to play
though right because you're walking
in to a discovered check yeah if he
continues with rook takes f7 and the
same plan we are speaking about with
knife e5
might still be possible but maybe david
will
find the harder option well work f7
actually may be
bad but it's hard to see because queen
dhl forces bishop back and i could take
your knight on f6
because everything is pinned
yeah there's a lot of tactics here i
mean it's just that i don't
will david see that he might he might um
but
you know it's it's it comes down to
almost a 50 50 percent chance between
you take you know stay three versus
you taking off seven and it's so
difficult
for to walk into a check right by taking
on c3 you're allowing a discovered check
but if david has been doing his tactics
if he feels like let me just take a
breath
it's just a check it's not checkmate
then he'll be able to take this knight
on c3 but i feel like it's a
really hard thing to do in a game like
this uh and he took on f7
oh i think he sees it i think he sees it
he's like
look at him he's like look at him yeah
he's got this i wish we could hear him
right now
yeah oh no it's the ice skater right
it's it's just going right across the
board it's not a background checkmate
goodness because the bishop can block
but he wants to look at him
he's getting ready yeah he just shook
his head he's like shaking off his
sleeve
you know he's waking up yeah he's
finally waking up he thought
head shake that was it yeah it's no
longer ah
and david pakman also sees it the
reactions are absolutely hilarious
he's like boss champ exactly
you see the evaluation bar say checkmate
in five moves
it's not so straightforward because it's
not check check check check mate
but he found queen d8 so step one
complete after bishop f8 though
will he see that the rook is pinned and
then he can win this
knight and then the rook next or will he
say i'm gonna take your bishop because
that's hanging which is
still not a bad decision for white right
you're taking a piece there and the rook
is still pinned but
i wonder if he is going to see queen
takes f6
next as the rook is pinned to the king
these are some
very this is a very good position very
promising position for xqc
no matter what happens and yeah
only one move available for david pakman
yeah i'm gonna say in positions like
this
david should not be wasting any time
because clearly can't move his rook and
knight is a free piece he should spend a
second
good he brings it back and will
xqc find the dagger queen
takes f6 the dagger the bing the bang
and the boom all at once with the queen
taking on f7
this is uh this is the moment you guys
leave
chaplain oh i'm nervous honestly
my heart is racing i have to admit i
hope he finds it
because then we'll get an armageddon
maybe yeah oregon is always fun to watch
too
yeah and i think he's very focused
he is david pakman was baited into this
you know he won a piece which was great
but then his king started feeling a
little iffy
and that's what happens when you leave
the queens on the board he could have
traded queens but then he was worried
earlier
i'll just show that position really
quickly and he was worried about his
knight coming into c7 so he decided to
keep the queens on the board and maybe
andre you said this earlier because he
lost in an end game when he was actually
winning
maybe he just doesn't want to get to an
end game yeah maybe he's a little bit
scared
and so here we sit
i is he going to take on f6 i feel like
the more he thinks
the more he's going gonna doubt himself
a little right it's like and these guys
oh
he takes the rook okay it's so good so
good
but he's still winning he's going to
take his bishop next
that bishop is under attack do you think
he'll see it or he'll try to save his
knight instead
well thankfully for him taking the
bishop also defends the knight
but and he but xcc doesn't seem that
thrilled
you see him shaking his head yeah maybe
he saw
he could play queen takes f6 right after
he played it but i mean there's no going
back now
i think it's just his thinking face
honestly okay
well he hasn't played queen takes c8 and
that's a worrying sign
as he did just decide to take that look
there
that's what i was saying i don't think
oh okay oh
the check wait it's one side away
so close yeah knight d7 is actually
knight b d7 is actually going to be
and block the check right blocks the
check the rook protects the bishop the
bishop can also block on
d7 and the reason why i will say this
game is so far from over
is there's a king on f7 so even if you
block the first check
i don't think that david is happy about
his king being out here
and david is a good player we saw it in
the match-up
against hafu we're seeing it again today
like he's capable
even having his king on the open he's
capable of
stifling and styming his opponent's
threats and then playing for a win
himself but
what do you two think do you think that
the weak king is going to
pose him some serious problems i feel
like it
is it is going to pose a little bit of
problem but i'm a little bit worried
about xqc's time as well
and he plays 97 just defending the
bishop and also developing the knight
black is pretty well defended here i
don't know
how much xpc can come after the black
king here yeah
even with quesadilla check there's
always kg7 or something
right we just don't have enough pieces
because black has
three minor pieces for the rook that was
lost that's
a ton of material yeah
so how to press forward here maybe
f4 at some point but f4 will allow
queen to b6 check getting those queens
off the board
and that should make black's king feel a
lot better
yeah syria should be going for
comfortable moves especially with his
time
situation like rook d1 hopefully
he do one you know simple plans so that
the bishop has to stay on
c8 and develop the knights um
i'm more worried about his time though
yeah
the the time is yep clock this is a yep
clock moment guys
um clock sticking down xqc needs to
play some active chest but it's a little
bit hard finding a clear plan in a
position where you're down material and
you can't really attack his king anymore
he's he's not down that much but okay he
goes for the one check the kim ji
king g7 will secure the king well indeed
and then what will his follow-up be will
he try to
bring his knight to b5 he's shown that
he likes knight getting that square will
play rook to b1
to attack the queen it's
not super easy for black to continue
either but with the three minor pieces
uh of course david pakman's position is
excellent
yeah rook b1 would be like the fastest
thing for time saving because he could
get another tempo after rook
b3 um but now there's also a
huge weakness on e6 so his knight is
pretty useful you could not maneuver
like knight b5 knight c7
there's lots of ideas for him even
though he's down yeah
getting the knight to e6 would be
fantastic and
nemo what do you think is he going to go
for knight b5 or
maybe move the rook or play f4
with a too many options yes oh it plays
95. i like the prediction
okay andrea seems like you're turning
into
the uh the pog whisperer here i think
i'm just the pega whisperer we get each
other you know oh my brain
i always i always get jokes how well
doing many similar vegan moments the
move is great it also threatens rook to
be one trapping the queen on b2 so that
queen needs to move its way
back with the move like queen of b4 and
that way your king starts feeling a
little bit safer as your queen is
trying to maybe even get back to e7 but
the queen is in danger of being trapped
which is not actually easy to see
for either player yeah i i do think that
david pacman even going by the basic
principles of positions in which he's up
material he should play queen before
it's almost his only move as well so
let's see if he plays it
i think considering earlier he didn't
realize the danger of queen b2
i have a feeling he might not see rook
b1
that is true too that is very very true
i honestly it's it's like
yeah if he sees queen before this game
is gonna be very difficult for xqc to
play but if he if you know if he if he
doesn't see it
then xqc has every single chance to win
this position well let's go back
to that thought about match one where we
got to an
end game and that's when david didn't
feel comfortable so perhaps
because that he will not want to trade
queens but we can ask him in the
interview i
have no degree of certainty yeah with
respect to that notion but
it doesn't seem like he wants to trade
queens yeah that would definitely be his
best bet
he might just be reluctant for any queen
trade which is holding him back a lot
and andre your idea with knight coming
to c7 and that you
you looked at e6 square you said that's
one
where my pieces belong whether it's my
queen or my knight and that knight would
head right to e6
and cause black some serious problems
with that check and hitting the bishop
as well so the knight is
trying to make a long journey from c3
into e6 and
the first step was definitely a good one
yeah that's the main thing i try to
teach
like any of my pogchamp students as well
like pointing out weak squares
immediately after move because then it's
very easy for them to formulate a plan
yeah that is a very very smart idea
and you know even despite being down
material there's always things to play
for right and that's a big part about
not giving up so
david's time is running down low as well
uh we might see a time scramble
yeah between these two players say what
i saw between half fu
oh the queen is oh wait that's actually
a really good move
because yeah oh he played quick wait no
that was quick
that was good he invited the plan
this is getting dangerous for the king
even though it saved the queen
right it was a trade-off now the queen
has the a3 square to jump to eventually
but you first have to move the rook away
and then andrea's plan
is going to show up on the board yeah
this is a very very good plan and you
bring
more material into the attack more
chances you'll have for
you know just causing mayhem in general
and david has to move this road
oh wait he that's that's a really really
interesting move
he's like i absolutely refuse to let
knight e6 happen
attacking the queen um wow
yeah that was a pretty brilliant move
but i think
i don't even know honestly the best
response for white yet
i have to calculate i think he needs to
play quickly and play queen to d3 and if
this rook moves from a8 you play rook to
b1 and try to get this knight
on b6 so the good news is the e6 square
is covered
the bad news is the knight goes in the
same line as a queen so
and also xqc's time is oh and he plays
96 anyways well he won't be losing the
queen but bishop takes e6
and uh white will have no more minor
pieces which also means his attack is
going to be a lot more difficult where
you don't have pieces
yeah with the queen d3 move it's
honestly a pretty good move like what
the plan robert pointed out but i don't
think xqc wants to give up on his plan
that he was so emotionally invested in
which is common mistake
that i also do a lot yeah and here david
can
take this knight directly on e6 but he
can actually move his king
and that's a very hard thing to do is
when you're in check and it looks like
pieces are coming after you to leave it
on that square especially considering
the bishop's seat hasn't moved yet
but he can he does take it he could have
moved his king first and that way the
knight would have been on a vulnerable
square so
we have a trade and rookie one next is a
very big threat but look at david pakman
go he attacks the queen on
uh e6 first david backmans are playing
very solidly
very very solidly like it's it's
something else to see you know because
most people in this
um in this podcamp so far i've been
mostly involved with pushing pieces
forward
not caring so much about what their
opponent does but david pakman has this
prophylactic kind of thinking going on
and it's really impressive because he's
like yeah my point wants to play
96 i'm going to stop that um on all of
these kind of ideas that
you have we don't see that often because
everyone tends to get a little bit more
tunnel vision
that's a really good observation time is
sticking
yeah the time oh yep clock guys get
clocked oh god no
no okay so rook b1 i understand the
point but
will david pakman see that he can
actually finally
you take the queen the black rook takes
the white queen and if you take here
then the white
the black queen continues to be crazy
and take rooks before
finally taking the queen so let's go
back to the live board because i'm in
fact rookie six rook b2 so we are
trading
in b7 though
all right no hesitation there i actually
think the rooks are better than the
minor pieces
in this game i do think so too um
just because i feel like xqc can utilize
them a lot better than
david pac-man will know how to use a
bishop at night
realistically speaking it's just not
something you
get very often i feel like in when
you're newer to chess
so you're like trying to coordinate
these two knights in a bishop but the
rooks
you know they just want to line up yeah
rip rose
rook bros exactly so
wait rook d8 and that hits like the
knights it hits the bishop here things
are getting awkward
yeah oh he plays it so fast wow look at
that
tactical genius good excuse right here
and now it is looking the game is
turning in xqc's favor not that he's
better just yet
but we've seen that david pakman you
know he's been so solid throughout right
now it's getting uncomfortable with
all of his minor pieces under threat by
these rooks
wow look at that very impressive taco
gameplay from xqc
um his time is running low but you know
the the instincts are there
from a pro gamer and look at this david
pakman about to even up the clock
situation as he is
going into 22 21 and a 26
main weakness oh that's a night that you
can just take
oh so if xg does it
look at that oh my gosh so david can
take on e4
the free pawn he does it
push f3 all right
the reason i don't love it is because
bishop c5 check but i think that david
without time is just going to retreat as
knight
as he did and good move
hitting the pawn putting some pressure
on the night though the knight is
protected you just can't forget
that certain pieces are defended now
what you guys were saying earlier about
the rooks being easier like personally i
prefer the minor pieces but at this
level
just like these natural rook moves are
so much easier to find
yeah you just have to put your uh rooks
together and they'll be safe but with
minor pieces you can lose them at any
time
right and the knight on b7 in particular
is an awkward piece bring this rook to
d5
and you just can coordinate them so well
rook e3 is also plenty good just do not
fall victim to the ice skater right you
need to you need to make space for your
king at some point
so xcc first needs to save his rook he
just did that
and eventually he needs to push some of
his pawns from his king preferably
his g-pawn yeah and
aslan's excuse he doesn't lose his rook
accidentally he he's defending his work
really well
um david is going to struggle a little
bit with finding moves he's finally up
yeah about time too up on time this is a
big
big you know switch from from the most
of the game
and look at him go with g4 maybe he'll
try to h4 and create a checkmating net
oh that'd be beautiful but i think david
trying to defend with the rook h8 maybe
oh that's just so passive there must be
a checkmate playing rook to d5 as well
yeah would be beautiful oh
okay he keeps hitting himself in the
head yeah i don't know what he's seeing
but uh
he's definitely better oh g5 bishop g5
okay
so so now you don't no longer have h4
but
i don't know about losing the f pawn
though yeah he doubled up his rooks
which is
stacking the rooks generally a good
strategy but not when it caused jobs
but look david pakman in only 8.7
seconds when he made that move
and h3 xqc okay now
whoa hitting the rock right but rick d1
is going to come back
okay we're defending that's good too
and now he could go f4 g5 yeah f4 would
be a really good move here foreign
wow look at him look at that knight d5
would be there it is but david pac-man
going right after the pawn and looking
out okay he's going for the past
pawn instead i like this this is
really good stuff from both sides very
impressive how they're performing at a
time pressure
so david wants to bring his knight to f4
it looks like that's kind of the idea
but look at xqc
bring his rook in the a6 pawn can be
captured if he wants it or rook to d1
bring his next rookie f6 wait that's a
freak
there's the guy that the head smack came
in it's okay
but he's okay if he just takes an a6
okay rookie seven checks also fine he
lost a very valuable pawn but there's so
many chances here yeah
another pass pawn maybe maybe the pin is
actually going to work in xqc's favor
too just because your pieces are
tied down if rookie six happens you'll
probably lose the eight pawn
a lot of good chances here for white
wasn't rook
there we go good move for k7 the knight
can't move and the
oh the works hanging the vocabulary what
happened
he took it xqc sees it and wins the rook
david all right this is looking like
pressure again this is looking like
xqc's game now
we're going to see armageddon sqc
look at that xqc did not crumble on
their time pressure
and so he needs to make sure he keeps
his rooks defending king g7
bring your rook to f5 or to f3 just make
sure you do not drop that rook
and bring oh he's going for the
checkmate yeah but bishop g3 oh
okay oh but it's okay but it's okay
white still has really good practical
winning chances in this position with
the two passports oh no
it's not over guys it's not over push
the all over
is okay too but push that a pawn i
really wish we could have heard his
raging moments but
yes gosh and king king d3
he needs to make sure not to go king d5
because if he goes king d5 there'll be
knight b6
do not go king d5 because knight b6
forks
i'm holding oh there's still very good
chance i mean xqc
technically is still winning this
tradition just because for another rook
no
okay good move by xqc and david knight
b6
good move by him so you need to keep the
rook on the a file to so you don't drop
your passport
oh god there goes the other rook oh no
oh oh no
oh man oh okay that that
this was such a great game that was an
amazing game
that was painful but it's not over yet
it's not over yet he does have a pass
pawn and he king d5 if he can bring that
king in but
does knight c7 check if dave pacquiao
finds knight c7
if he doesn't die
[Music]
and wow xqc
unfortunately for him he had two rooks
against two minor pieces but both of his
rooks have now been captured
and he's just going to try and push his
past pawn hoping that he can get to the
other side
it just seems like david pakman has it
under control now
what a game this was it was a very good
game by excuse just the time at the end
if he goes king e8 or c7 oh he's he
needs to make sure he does not bring his
king
and he brings his bishop back to stop
there guys he sees it
he's not allowing any more room for
counterparty bishop a5
keep that bishop on the diagonal yeah
once what does he get that c
pawn oh david looks like he he he's just
um he just smacked his head a little bit
over there i'm not sure if he sees
bishop
i'm sure he's going to find a way to um
play bishop a5 but
he says oh my goodness i'm going to
attack the knight for
the pawn on c7
you know the thing is if king of six
then okay he brought the knight up king
to d6 now
oh and if he goes knight e4 he might be
94 to keep checking he might think that
no look at that no not a six okay
wow that's that's a really good move
okay but this this good chance is still
here still it's not over it's not over
it's definitely not over very good
chances for xqc to hold this position
and now knight b8 could have been played
to take a closer look
oh we're just going to create the
passport and then the king black's king
is really close
to the to white's pass pawn so the
promotion is going to happen from
from david so david breaks free that
pawn king c8
to b7 would be like the only chance that
you have to try to chase that
knight away but it seems like david
pakman
he stood some serious pressure on this
one
oh my gosh it feels like david is during
time pressure like we saw earlier and uh
the other day he's he he doesn't do too
well
under time pressure so he's only oh no
oh he gave up the night
and he just lost the night there okay
but he promotes but does he know how to
use a queen yeah yeah
i don't know if he knows how to win this
thing but he's a draw is still winning
for him unfortunately for xqc
that's right a draw still winning but
i'm not sure if he knows how to use a
queen to
queen and king combo for this the idea
is that you have to check the king so
that the king goes in front of your the
past pawn on c8 and then you bring your
king over slowly to capture the pawn
but um that's a very advanced end game
idea
right especially in a position like this
because you're forcing the opponent's
king up the board like queen f6
that's not the right start but he can
just give checks forever
and as you said make the draw and that
way when the match
and he knows this too yeah he definitely
he can just stack his queen for c7
then take the h pawn he can force the
draw in many ways
i mean force winning this match right
queen e4 check this is something that
um i oh he allowed the queen
that's all right it's uh yeah i i think
he didn't see that but the king is close
enough to the pawn where
he's going to be able to capture it and
this will be a fourth straw
and everything is yelling it's like he
didn't expect this to be a draw
i really wish the xcc were streaming so
we could have heard his thoughts
that was one of if not the best games
of both the first and this pog champs i
mean that wasn't really something
it was very impressive xbc played very
well sir david
yeah huge respect to both players xcc
played amazingly and so did david of
course but xqc had a very good winning
chances here you know
might see a even better gameplay from
his next game
well we'll hear from the players in just
a few moments we're going to take
our final break and when we return we
will have xqc and david pakman
and hear how they feel after what was an
epic battle
and we return with both david pakman and
xqc and david we'll start with you
congratulations and
i have to ask how nervous were you down
the stretch of that second game
when you both were in immense time
trouble i i was getting pretty nervous
yeah and
what i tried to remember was with
increment last time in game two
i just played the entire rest of the
game as if i had 25 seconds left even
though i had built it back up to like
two minutes so i tried to remember that
that was not the case this time
but this it was a major major collapse
and i'm lucky to have uh i mean listen
after last match i'll take any win
that i can get but um there was a bit of
a collapse there we're gonna have to be
analyzing that one for a while
and xuc you played a really great second
game
with some aggressive play there after
you had blundered a piece
did you feel like your gameplay was
better today because we were all quite
impressed
uh no i i blundered so hard i was kind
of defeated there dude
but my my boy a white shirt walter
had to push a draw on a 600 elo player
come on man i dropped it
come on i was going for the home
stretcher dude
yes well listen i'm lucky to have gotten
the draw i almost lost so
all right yeah you both played really
really well today
was an amazing amazing game
yeah and well let's look at the second
game because the first game
uh was pretty wild as was the second one
and
we'll go back to that critical moment
where david you
did not trade queens uh when you could
have when you were up a piece
was that because you were having some
ptsd
from last week against hafu in the end
game wait so this is game two which move
um you went your queen out to b6 on move
when you could have traded queens off
for instance and you were up a piece for
a pawn at this point uh yeah
yeah i mean i guess i just didn't see
any particularly good reason to trade
the queens
and then it would have brought i just
you know obviously i'm terrible at this
so who knows
why i would do anything but don't be so
hard on yourself
you're doing great you're doing great
you need to be so hard for yourself
i couldn't justify trading the queens so
i figured
that there was maybe some opportunity
with the two knights and the bishops
stacked up on the bnc
files to maybe later get the queen there
and and in fact had i not collapsed
later
i was looking at taking either the c
pawn or the knight on c3 but i never got
got the time really because things fell
apart
in xuc you went for a vicious attack
with
knight takes f7 and after rook takes f7
it was actually you who had a chance to
end the game pretty quickly because you
brought the queen down
i was like that's a good start and after
bishop f8 did you consider the move
queen takes knight on f6 listen
i it's one of those things where like
good chess players see like all
scenarios and they see them through
like if i think of a scenario and i see
it through and
there's another one that appears it's
like i forget what the other one was
like and i can't like
like do a fusion and i i didn't remember
that
um with that new line of thought that
rook was pinned
right and i was like okay well oh what
will they queen
i've forgotten uh that i already thought
that that plan outs
so i i didn't know like i just forgot
that it was pending it's just bad that
was a very complex way of saying he just
missed the pin but i see
yeah we we get it and we understand
well he's you're juggling variations
right and david i'm sure you can attest
to this as well
that when you're dealing with so many
different ideas that
in one line you may remember a certain
tactic but in another
you forget right uh yes
forgetting is um i mean i've forgotten
way more than i've remembered in this
game already that's the crazy thing
and did with that queen trade middle i
was like dude
take my queen dude take it man if you
want to win did
did i want to see blood man if you're
going to get the w out of this
i want you to fight for it dude come get
my pieces bro
this is oh that's interesting i like
that yeah
and i guess you guys did get into this
queenless position
and it started to turn in xqc's favor
where
david you were in time trouble and you
were fending it off for
a while but then you got into this
position where your
night was pinned i'm going to go to that
moment right now and unfortunately
you didn't either recall that your rook
was hanging or you just didn't see
that the rook on f1 was staring down
through your night the rook and f8
no it was a fiasco and i mean i got
lucky on a couple of uh
forks at the end where i was able to
pick up some ponds and sort of like
salvage it but it was uh
it was by sheer instinct alone and my
instinct is usually not super good
so that was it was lucky for everybody
also
he knows scope my uh my rook and i
didn't even see it he slid
all across the board yep no scope yep
that was a nice find
that was a clutch saved by you david i
think up in the up
up until that point i was like we're
good we're going to armageddon
yeah we thought so too yeah cause xcc
you were just trying to give that quick
checkmate right you were trying to do
the ladder with the rooks and yeah i was
trying to do
the scissor lift or whatever you call
that or you like uh like
like chick chick chick chick chick chick
yeah yeah yeah the ladder yep
yeah i was certainly aware that that
could be coming so i was trying to think
of
you know making sure i had a spot to
kind of hide the king if it came to that
and unfortunately like with f5 and h5
covered by the pawn uh i was i knew i
needed
i knew i needed forks i was looking for
utensils i would have taken anything but
i was looking for forks
well you got one of them and then xqc
still had a good position and
unfortunately
for him he dropped the rook here on a8
when the knight came to b6 so
what's interesting is i'm looking at the
evaluation bar when i got this fork
it went more in his favor well
i wouldn't necessarily agree with that
it's it's kind of complicated the
position
is still winning for white because of
the past pawn
and xqc started on the right foot and he
tried to push that opponent all the way
through
but unfortunately for him you were being
all tricky with your night and night
yeah
do you think that night is the trickiest
piece for you guys because i feel like
that's been the theme in pogchamps
you know what you know i i feel like
lately after doing a bunch of puzzles i
think night is the only
piece that actually put thought in like
um
yeah i agree and i agree in that because
i know that it's trickier i feel like i
also am thinking way more about like
in two or three moves where could the
night be
yeah and after this i mean once you lost
the rook xtc there went your winning
chances
uh it felt and that dave was able to
secure the half point he needed so
what a crazy match it was andrea what
thoughts do you have of that
matchup any questions for either player
um i had a question for xqc like i
thought this was one of his best games
out of all pog champs
i know he took a day off or i don't know
how much of the day which is very rare
for him
were you preparing a little bit before
this like doing any puzzles today or
did you go into it like last time guys
before
i had this little uh rare tummy ache
because i was just chilling i was just
sleeping and napping
well you played very well but okay so
you didn't prepare yourself for it but
it's okay because he still did great
that's right um yeah am i am i out of
blue or do i have a chance to
redeem it um well
we don't know because these uh other two
players in your group will be playing
not tomorrow which is a rest day for the
day after so
we'll see how that shakes out but i
think that
you still have a chance and if not
you'll be in the constellation bracket
and we know that you can be a force in
that
cool okay sure make sense yeah and uh
david i have a question for you because
you know throughout
you've been very solid and maybe in the
first match your
first game the opening was a little bit
risky
it feels like you have a good foundation
so what is your chest
background like and what have you been
doing lately to work on your game
um my background is really about 18
months ago i just started playing online
um up until that point i did i was
extremely solid on how the pieces move
so like i would never
think you know a rook moves diagonally
like i was super solid on that type of
thing
but um no i mean i've just been playing
online for 18 months
and then just you know training training
for this quite frankly
well you've been training well it seems
and uh you have a very impressive
foundation as i've said and
it seems like you you know you're a very
solid player like you
know how to minimize the risk for
yourself most often and then that causes
problems for your opponent so i've been
impressed by that
now what was the riskiness of the in the
opening with just
the opening in general is a risky one so
i meant the first game against
hafu yeah oh oh and against hobart oh my
god that's what you call a gambit gone
bad i mean
it's called a gambit for a reason right
and uh i was on the the wrong end of
that one
yeah no today was a different story the
game of tofu is the one i was referring
to but it seems like you've shored that
up
and nemo any final questions before we
let these two players go
no i just have to say both players
played absolutely amazing today and it's
great to see xqc
you know play really really well and
there's always a chance to
you know win the last game um whether
it's
win the entire constellation bracket or
just win the last match there's a lot of
good great chances here for both of you
thank you well thank you both it was
awesome
all right thanks guys really appreciate
it all right guys have a great day
goodbye
you